this is Dr Knight I just met people fake
do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad arshad Muhammad arshad has
helped develop all of us is extremely
beneficial to do this course definitely
recommend this course
to access the free life-changing
training now
brothers and sisters and dear friends it
was lovely to see and Habib and sit in
one sitting and subhanallah
his other character which you can see
that his dad taught in may Allah bless
him that subhanallah he is so humble
that when he's standing he's like you
know what it's not befitting for me to
give a speech and it allows Zakir Naik
to give a speech ball and sisters but
before he does that he asks and requests
like a night to talk about a very
profound IO listen to this guy said Sean
and we're going to go through the Ayah
and it is so so profound and we do not
sometimes acknowledge this let's watch
this quickly and come back
of all time how I can
it was really represent our religion
Islam Buddhism Dr Knight I just met
people
doctor can share he can talk with us
about what Allah said who is your
brothers who is a real family because I
know that I am say to Allah you promise
me you're gonna protect my family his
son don't follow him and Allah says or
not he said your son is not your family
because you don't believe you know maybe
about this doctor and I can talk about
it because he know better than me the
video that you saw the brown sisters as
you can see Habib is talking about
something so profound who are your
family who are your family when we talk
about family we'll talk about yes my
family is my wife my daughter my mother
my father my sister my uncle not what
Allah says this is the definition by
Allah yes biologically they are but what
do we say we say blood is thicker than
water biology that our family come first
before somebody else Iman is thicker
than blood meaning water blood yeah the
distance between water Brothers Iman is
is all the way up there why because
brothers and sisters go to the Quran we
go to the Quran what does Allah say he
tells us
Lord and said my Lord indeed my son is
of my family and indeed your promise is
true and you are the most just of judges
because what does it mean that
Allah saves him and his family that
obviously his family member but here is
saying that you you did promise me Allah
you're going to see my family about my
son drowned I told him to come aboard
with my one of his wives to come on
board they refused and they drowned
Allah says he said oh no indeed he is
not of your family indeed he is the one
whose work was other than righteous so
ask me not for that about which you have
no knowledge indeed I advise you lest
you be among the ignorant says my Lord I
seek refuge in you from us asking that
which I have no knowledge and unless you
forgive me and have mercy upon me I will
be among the losers this is taken in the
moment of the uncle over the knuckle and
Allah has reminded what is with him and
what he knows is far beyond what you can
comprehend what that teaches is the
following and what we learn from what
Habib is requesting which is deep
because it shows he has that Reflections
upon Allah our believer who's our real
family our real family is the Believers
brothers and sisters in the Battle of
butter a son had to fight his father hey
um nephew had to fight his uncle people
turned animation animosity between them
why because it was Iman against koffer
it was Iman against koffer not he's my
dad no no because that day he doesn't
want to know you that day if he has the
chance he will make sure you're finished
that is the difference and if you take
what Allah says you will not be thinking
my brother will never do that to me my
father will never do that to me my
sister my auntie my mother will never do
that to me
when it comes to the issue when things
when the last they say when Pooh hits
the fan brothers and sisters the
believer are the only one that's going
to be together and you're going to see
this divide that's going to happen where
you're going to be like subhanallah what
Allah and his messenger said was true
and this is what I wanted to give you
guys as a reminder I didn't want to see
anything else voila it is so profound
the Believers are your true true
Companions and family in this life and
in the Hereafter may Allah make our bond
between our brothers our born between
our sisters to be strong till this day
until we enter Jannah inshallah